FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
Welcome to episode number 74
of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
I'm back in San Francisco
after a little trek
over the east coast.
But it's good to be home.
How you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Back from a little trip
to China, and indeed
it is very nice to be home.
I am very happy
because today we have,
again, someone
else from our team.
We have Sara Robinson
to talk about--
I think it's probably
the latest API.
MARK MANDEL: The Cloud
Vision Intelligence API.
It just sounds smart.
I like the sound of it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very cool.
There was a really cool demo.
We talked with her during
Cloud Next on day one, I think.
She did an amazing demo.
We had a quick chat
about it, and she's back
to tell us even more.
So very excited.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, and
super excited to hear that.
After that, we have our
question of the week, where
we will be talking
about backup strategies
for persistent disks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
want to make sure
that whatever happens
to your machine,
the information isn't lost.
So how do you do that?
We'll be talking a little
bit about multiple options
and pricing and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So why don't we get stuck into
our cool things of the week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yup.
MARK MANDEL: So
to start that off,
we talked last week a little bit
about the cloud identity aware
proxy.
Basically, being able to lock
down your applications using
identity at a network level.
There's a new article that's
come out recently talking about
how, basically, to
get started with it.
And how you can use it
within your own applications.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
think it's pretty good,
because last week we
talked about it from a very
high-level point of view.
And this one is really like,
oh, so you're really interested?
This is how to do it.
So if you're truly
interested in improving
the security of your network,
dropping VPN instead using,
basically, identity or
SSH certificates and stuff
like that, go check it out.
There will be a link on
the show notes as always.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty neat.
It takes you through several
different authentication
options, from OpenID and
IAM, and a few other ones
as well, so that you
can pick and choose
the one that works
right for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
we have another cool thing
of the week that is very,
very cool, especially
because it's about Go design.
Our coworker Jaana Dogan
wrote an amazing article.
She is very well known
in the Go community.
She may be known also as Rakyll,
which is her GitHub name.
She wrote about how
to do distributor
tracing in Go, which is
kind of a hard thing to do.
So we've been
working on it lately,
and she wrote a very
good article explaining
what is the techniques--
what are the techniques
to be used, how to
use it, and even open
sourced the legal library that
allows you to use a trace ID
and send data around
different servers, all of that
powered by the context package.
So it's a very
interesting blog post,
especially if you write Go.
If you don't write Go, what
are you doing with your life?
Not that-- if you
don't write Go,
it is still a very
interesting one.
Because there's all the
distributor tracing,
all the problems that
are attached to it.
So it's definitely worth a read.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and it's super cool
to see that it has
direct integration
right with Stackdriver as well.
So you can see all your
distributed traces,
how long they took, all
that sort of good stuff too.
So you can see if there
is one particular part
of your micro-servers'
infrastructure breaking
something in some way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then the
third cool thing of the week.
It's a very interesting
one because I
have no idea what
it is, other than it
is the largest compute
engine job ever run,
which is 220,000 cores.
And those cores are
actually [INAUDIBLE] VMs,
which I guess makes sense,
because when you're running
220,000 cores, the fact that
you can get them for less money
makes a lot of sense.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I would have loved
to have seen the quota
increase request for this
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's like, yeah, I'd
like to run a little server.
Yeah, only 200,000 cores.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I don't--
it's going to be fine.
Everything is going to be fine.
What was he-- what
was he calculating?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
going to read this with--
it's like, I could be reading
some other language that I
don't understand and it
would sound the same.
So he explored 10 to the
17 hyper elliptic curves
of Genius 3 in an
effort to find curves
whose L functions can
be easily computed
and which have
potentially interesting
Sato-Tate distributions.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, of course.
Clearly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
So there is cool diagrams.
That's pretty much
what I can say.
But basically it's definitely,
definitely, heavy computation
going on.
And it is pretty
amazing to see that they
were able to just run it,
using VMs and everything is--
I mean, I was going to
say everything is simple.
The infrastructure
itself is pretty simple.
What--
MARK MANDEL: The maths
might be a little hard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: -- the math
behind it is, I have no idea.
But if someone knows what
this actually means, and they
can explain it in a
sentence, please let us know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we would love to--
yeah, send us an
audio transcription
and we'll put it on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That would be nice.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't
we go have a chat
with our good friend, Sara,
all about the Cloud Video
Intelligence API?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
I am very happy to welcome back
Sara Robinson to the Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
Hello Sara, how are you doing?
SARA ROBINSON: Hi Francesc.
I'm doing well.
Excited to be back
on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
happy to have you back
for a second or third time.
We're going to be talking
about some cool demos
that you did at
Google Cloud Next
during the keynote
of day two or three.
But before that, why
don't you tell us
a little bit about who you
are for those that have not
seen any of the many,
many episodes, and talks
that you've given before.
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate
with Mark and Francesc
on the Google Cloud
Platform team.
As a developer advocate,
we do a combination
of building demos, giving
talks to show developers
how to use different cloud
products, writing blog posts,
and bringing that feedback
back to the product team.
And I'm focusing primarily on
machine learning APIs and some
of our big data offerings.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
you were on stage
for a keynote-- what
was it, day one?
MARK MANDEL: It
was day one, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
did an amazing demo.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically everyone told us
that was, by far, their
favorite part of the whole day.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what was it about?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
I built a demo to showcase the
Video Intelligence API, which
we announced in private
beta on day one of Cloud
Next a couple of weeks ago.
What the Video
Intelligence API does
is it gives you
metadata on videos.
It makes it really easy
to search video content.
With the demo I wanted
to show that off.
So what the demo was,
I took a lot of videos
and ran them through
the Video API.
And the demo let you
visualize all the labels
it found in a video.
So it's able to tell you
there is a dog in the video,
starts at second one and
ends at second three.
So on the page for
an individual video,
you'll be able to see
all the granular data
on what different
labels it found
at which points in the video.
Then with all that
metadata from the API
you're also able to
easily implement search
across a large
library of videos.
So I showed how you could
search the library of videos
that I had-- a lot of the videos
were from the Google YouTube
channel.
So I did a search
of baseball videos.
I wanted to be able to show
what a large media company might
be able to do with the API.
Let's say they had hours and
hours of video footage sitting
in storage buckets Maybe they're
a sports media company that
has hours of sports
video, but they only
want to find the content
with a baseball field in it.
Maybe they're creating
some sort of sizzle reel
at the end of the week to
highlight, specifically,
baseball content.
So if you were to
do this manually,
you would have to have
someone on your team
go through all those
hours of footage.
Watch the video and write down
the times when all the baseball
clips appeared.
With the Video API, with all
the metadata you get back,
you can pretty easily
implement search
because you're just
searching the JSON that's
returned from the API.
And it will tell you not only
which videos have exactly
what you're looking for,
but when in the videos
your search term appears.
So the demo was
essentially built
to showcase those two features.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice!
So could you tell
us a little bit more
about what does it do exactly?
Because when you tell us about,
oh, it's able to see things,
like, it's able to recognize
a baseball stadium.
I directly think about
the Cloud Vision API.
But when you-- then you say
when in the clip, it makes
me think about a Speech API
that recognizes over time.
Where does this fit in between?
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
That's a good question.
So right now, it doesn't
do anything with audio yet.
But people might see the API
and think, well, isn't this just
the Vision API taking a frame
and analyzing it and then
aggregating that content?
So it does do that.
The Video API samples images
at one frame per second,
and it uses an image
classifier that's
similar to the Vision API.
And it does this for
every scene in the video.
But the core of the Video API--
the real magic behind
it-- is that when they're
done processing a video,
taking all the frames,
they have a separate video
aggregation classifier,
and then this will
analyze all the features
throughout the video.
And then at a high
level it will be
able to tell you what
is this video about.
So let's say you had a
video of costumes and candy.
It could tell you this is
a video about Halloween.
So that aggregation
classifier is really
like the secret sauce
of the Video API.
To build it they
trained this model
on many, many YouTube videos
to be able to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When you said
video with costumes and candy,
actually, I thought about
Katy Perry, but that's me.
SARA ROBINSON: That works too.
I don't know if the model
is ready to detect that yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So if you
have one frame per second
and you're analyzing
all of those,
there's a bunch of the frames
that are pretty much the same,
right?
But all of a sudden
there is also
changes, like, you go from
seeing a house to seeing
a shark dancing, or whatever.
Is there something
related to that
which can allow
you to understand
the structure of the video
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
There is a feature called
shot change detection.
What this does is it's
able to detect every scene
change in a video.
So as you said, let's say
you have a vacation video
and you're panning
to some mountains,
and then you move it around
to show some people jumping
up and down.
It's able to detect
whenever the scene changes.
And if you request shot change
detection in the annotation
types that you want
back, it will tell you--
it will essentially give you
a JSON object of the start
and end time for every
different scene change
throughout your video.
So you can do this
to create a highlight
reel of your own video.
So that you know exactly
which points in the video
the scene changed.
MARK MANDEL: So you
mentioned something
in the previous comment you
made which made me think
of the Vision API as well, which
was that it sounds like you can
pick and choose which features
the Video API actually
goes and finds within it.
I know with a Vision API you
can choose emotion recognition,
or possibly location.
It sounds like
with the Video API
you can also do something
similar there too.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
right now there
is label detection and
shot change detection.
But there is definitely more
in the works coming soon
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So what are the things that
you can build with this?
Because one of the things
that I was imagining is--
imagine that you have a
very long video, right?
And you're like, oh, I remember
that I was watching this video,
and the last thing
I saw was that scene
where you can see a train.
So you could say, hey, go to
the scene that has a train.
Would that work?
Is that something that
people are building?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah.
I think the biggest use case
for this is searching videos.
Movie navigation like
you just brought up
is also a good point which
is related to search.
So because you get metadata on
what's happening in every scene
it's pretty easy to build an app
that will go to specific scenes
throughout the video.
Say you want to
use the shot change
detection to show the frame
at each point in time,
and then go to a
certain frame based
on that image, or a
specific search term.
So navigation is definitely one,
navigating throughout a movie.
The biggest use case I see
is searching large libraries
of video content.
A lot of sites have
a way for users
to upload images and video.
Or media companies
could have lots
of video content sitting around
that they need to analyze.
Or maybe they don't have
any search implemented
on it right now and want to
add search functionality to it.
And I can actually talk
about two companies
that have been using the API to
implement something like this.
So the first one
is called Cantemo,
and they are a media
asset management company.
What they do-- their
customers are anyone
with a lot of video content.
Could be an individual
or a company
that has a lot of videos.
And they make it
easy to, essentially,
manage your video library.
So when you upload a
video to their service
they'll transcode it for you.
And they're using the Video
API to improve their search.
So this way they can make
it so customers can easily
search for, like you said,
find all my videos of the train
and it'll know exactly at which
point in the video that occurs.
So that's one example of a media
company using the Video API.
Another company is Wix.
Wix is a service, for those
of you that don't know,
that lets anybody
create a web site.
And you don't have
to be a developer
to be able to create
a website on Wix.
They're using the Video API
for what they call Wix Media
Platform, which is a platform
that they use to support users
that are uploading
a lot of images
and video files every day.
So when a user uploads a video,
or someone is building a web
site and one of their
users uploads a video,
the Wix Media Platform
will transcode it.
Then they'll use the Video
API, along with shot change
detection-- so they use both
shot change detection and label
detection--
to grab the main
images from the video
so that they can show users
the highlights of what
is this video about.
They also use the
metadata returned
to add tags to their videos,
and then with this they're
also able to add search.
So if they've got a website that
has a lot of user video content
it makes it easy for users to
search, both within a video
and in an entire
library of videos.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was wondering if there
is some of the features
that we've seen
and we've used on Cloud Vision
API, if those are available
In Cloud Video Intelligence API.
Specifically, I'm thinking
about that amazing demo
that we had a Google IO
and, I think, GCP Next too,
which was the Emotobooth.
You remember that it
takes a picture of you
and according to the reaction
of your face, the feeling
that-- if you are smiling
or you have anger,
it makes the background
a little bit different.
I was wondering if the
Cloud Video Intelligence
API allows you to do
things like, hey, find me
all the faces in a video.
Or find a face that is smiling.
This kind of thing.
Is this something that
is already supported?
SARA ROBINSON: So right now only
label protection is supported,
but that's definitely
something that we've
gotten a lot of feedback on.
And the team is working on
adding more of those features
into the Video API.
So one thing that was really
popular at the Vision API
is the inappropriate
content detection.
So you pass it an
image, it's able to tell
you is this image appropriate
or not, which eliminates
the need for a lot of manual
classification on images
if you've got a site
where users are uploading
a ton of images every day.
Instead of having somebody
manually flag those images
you can use the Vision
API safe search detection
method to do that.
That is something that obviously
has a big use case for videos
as well, and we're working
on adding more features to it
soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean, I guess
for any of those you could also
use the shot frame detection,
and go find one of the frames
and use that as the input
to the Cloud Vision API
and play with that.
Is that something
that you have tried?
SARA ROBINSON: I haven't
tried that personally,
but that's definitely something
you could do right now.
So if there was a
specific label that
was returned from
your video, you
would know exactly
which frame to go
so you can grab that frame.
The times it returns
are in microseconds,
so you could grab that
exact frame that you wanted
and send it to the Vision
API to run a face detection
or safe search detection on it
to get more data on your video.
MARK MANDEL: I've been
thinking about trying
to run it through
security camera
footage, like, certain
stuff outside my house.
Be like, show me
all the times there
was a person sitting
at my front doorstep.
SARA ROBINSON: That would
be a great use case.
And the API right
now can probably
recognize that there there's
a person in the scene.
So if you find the scene
that has a person in it,
you can go ahead and send
that to the Vision API
to get more data on is this
person happy, or angry,
or surprised.
MARK MANDEL: Or maybe
catch the coyotes
that have been roaming
my neighborhood recently.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
Figure out exactly what
times they go by your house.
MARK MANDEL: So let's talk about
the technology behind this.
Can you talk a bit about--
I know you mentioned the
YouTube dataset-- but can
you talk about
what's powering this?
Is this another
TensorFlow project?
SARA ROBINSON: So there's a
couple of models powering it.
They use the YouTube videos to
train their video aggregation
classifier.
And then it samples
images, I mentioned before,
at one frame per second.
To do this it's using a
custom image classifier,
which is similar
to the Vision API,
but a little bit different.
And that's what it's using
to go through the video
and grab an image
from every scene.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
one of the things
that I really like about
these kind of APIs--
specifically Cloud Vision
API, Video Intelligence API,
and also speech
APIs-- is that you
can start building
really cool demos that
are very interactive.
So I feel like lots of people
that are not necessarily
deeply technical could take
some benefits out of this
and create very artsy demos.
Is this easy to use?
How does it work?
SARA ROBINSON: Definitely, yeah.
It's very easy to use.
One thing that I love
about our machine
learning APIs is
that they give you
access to a pre-trained
machine learning model
with just one REST API request.
So I called them our
friendly machine learning.
If you don't have much of
machine learning or data
science background these
are really accessible.
All you need to know how to
do is make a REST API request
and you get access to all of
this machine learning data.
The video API is
very easy to use.
All you need to do is pass
it the URL of your video
in Google Cloud Storage, which
is our object storage tool.
So right now that's what's
supported for making a request.
So once you get your video in
cloud storage you send that
video URL and your
API request, you also
tell it which types of
detection you want to do.
Right now you should do either
label detection or a shot
change detection, and that
will kick off an operation.
One thing you can also
pass into your request
is an output URL for the JSON
to be sent in cloud storage.
So if you want to
store the annotation
JSON in cloud
storage, you can just
pass that URL into your request.
And then when the Video
API is done processing it
will write it to cloud storage.
If you want the--
Yeah, that's a really
useful feature.
I actually used that for
the demo that I built.
If you want the annotations
right away, all you need to do
is just ping the operation ID
and see what the status is.
It will give you a progress
on how far along it is.
Once it's done it will return
the annotations to you.
MARK MANDEL: I think that
would be a neat way integrating
with Firebase Storage as well.
SARA ROBINSON: Definitely.
I didn't use Firebase for this,
but I used Cloud Functions
to build the demo.
So what I did was I had
a Google Cloud storage
bucket that had all my videos,
and I had a class function
listening on that bucket.
So whenever a new
file is added it
checked if it was a video file.
If it was, it would
send it to the API.
And because I didn't need
annotations right away
I just had it output the results
to a separate cloud storage
bucket with the annotation JSON.
Then I used Node on App
Engine for the front end.
So I wasn't calling
the Video API directly
from the App Engine
app, all it did
was grab all the videos
from the cloud storage
bucket and their associated
metadata from the other bucket.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So this
gave me two questions.
The first one, is
that code open-source?
SARA ROBINSON: That's
a good question.
The answer is yes,
hopefully soon.
I'm starting on that
process this week.
So once the code
is open source I'm
hoping to do a
blog post about it,
and I'll give you a link to
add to the show notes as well.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I expect by the time this comes
out you should have it done.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
that's the goal.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The second
question is, how fast is this?
Like you said, you can give
the URL for a YouTube video,
let's say, a video on
Google Cloud Storage.
Let's say that the
video is one minute.
How long should I
expect this to take?
Seconds?
Micro-seconds?
Minutes?
Hours?
SARA ROBINSON: Right now
it takes about one fourth
of the time of the video.
So for your one-minute video
it would take about 15 seconds
to run the annotations, which
is actually pretty fast.
So it's not real time, but you
can get the annotation results
pretty fast.
What would take
a while is if you
had a large library of videos,
maybe terabytes of videos,
it could take a matter
of days to process.
But right now I've seen it
about one fourth the length
of the video.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Now, I was considering
it because if you
want to build a demo
that feels snappy,
then you could actually make it.
If you have a video that
is around 10 seconds then
it's going to take one or
two seconds to process that.
That is awesome.
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about--
and probably you're
going to tell me
that the answer is no
or this is top secret,
but is there any way of
doing video streaming
and getting streaming
labels and stuff like that?
Is this something
that anyone has asked?
Or I'm just crazy?
SARA ROBINSON: Oh, do you
mean getting the labels
from your video as it comes in?
Or through a real
time video stream?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually
having the input to the API
being a real video
stream and getting
a stream of notifications
or JSON containing
the current label
for the current
[INAUDIBLE] that
is being processed
or something like that.
I don't know.
Maybe it's crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
don't think it's crazy.
It's actually a great idea.
That is not supported right
now, but I can pass the feedback
along to the right people.
It's interesting you bring up
streaming because our Speech
API does that.
It supports either
batch or streaming mode,
so you send it a complete
audio file in cloud storage,
or you can send out
a stream of audio,
and as the API transcribes that
it will give you the results.
MARK MANDEL: I guess
people are just
going to have to wait and see.
So if people want to get
started playing with the Video
Intelligence API,
how can they do that?
SARA ROBINSON: They can go
to cloud.google.com/video
intelligence.
And they need to fill
out a form to sign up
for the private beta.
It's private beta right now.
So just fill out that
form, and then you
should receive a
notification soon after that.
And I would love to hear
anybody's feedback on it that's
part of the private
beta trying it out.
They can they can find
me on Twitter @SRobTweets
and you can put it in
the show notes as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we will.
It's still private
beta, so I'm sure
you have not seen many
projects, but what
is the coolest usage
you've seen of this API?
SARA ROBINSON: I've seen
some cool visualizations
of how people are displaying
the labels from their video.
The main use cases
I've seen for customers
are Cantemo and Wix,
which I mentioned before.
I've seen some cool
integrations with D3
because you get pretty
granular label data
from every scene in your video.
We used a little bit
of D3 in the demo.
But I've seen some
interesting line graphs
to show how the labels
and objects are changing
as you move throughout a video.
I'm definitely excited to see
what else people build with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I'm going to definitely
play with it.
It's lots of fun
SARA ROBINSON:
It's a ton of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're
running out of time,
but is there anything else
that you'd like to add?
SARA ROBINSON: I think I
covered pretty much everything.
I'm really excited to
see where this goes
and what else people do with it.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Sara, thank you
so much for joining us.
Always a pleasure to
have you on the podcast.
SARA ROBINSON: Thank
you for having me!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: I'm always super
happy when members of our team
get to pop by on the podcast.
Sara, no exception there.
Thank you so much for
joining us to come talk
to us about the Video
Intelligence API.
We should make a mention--
Sara talked about it a bit
when we interviewed her--
there is an open source
version of the code
that she showed in the demo.
That's available up on GitHub.
So we'll make sure there's a
link to that in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
This is actually
a very advanced technology.
If you told me five years
ago, you just give a video
and it describes it, I would
be, like, yeah, sure, whatever.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the fact that now you
can do that with a JSON
API, that's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: JSON
powers the internet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So, hopefully people will go and
check out that repo on GitHub
and try to modify it and do
some cool things with it.
I hope that we'll see
some amazing demos derived
from this one.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, why
don't we get stuck
into our question of the week.
So the situation is thusly--
say I've got one or
more virtual machines,
they have some data on them
and some sort of application
running on them as well.
And say the data on
those is going to change.
The classic example--
which people
don't do probably
as much any more--
is something like an FTP
server or something similar.
That kind of scenario.
What are my options,
or the best practices
I should use for making
sure that data is backed up?
Because I want to make sure
that if something bad happens
to that VM or the disk gets
corrupted in some crazy way,
which shouldn't
happen but who knows,
what can I use to make
sure that I can recover
from that relatively quickly?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
question comes from FRWillia23.
Free Willy, maybe?
I don't know.
I think that it is pretty
interesting because you
were saying in case the disk
gets a corruption or something,
that will never happen.
But your software could
have a bug, right,
so you could somehow wipe all
the data on your hard disk.
This is something that
happens, and this is something
that I've personally done.
It is not fun.
So you want to make sure
that you keep copies.
The question has a very
obvious answer, which
is, just use disk snapshots.
Because they're really
made for that, right?
I thought that was
probably the only answer,
but we also started
chatting about, well,
could we do the same thing
with Google Cloud Storage?
Especially because with
Google Cloud Storage
you have Nearline
and Coldline, which
are classes of
storage that allow
you to store the same data
with the same durability.
But with less-- basically,
it takes a little bit
longer to access,
but it's way cheaper.
So we're just
wondering, oh, it's
probably the best solution.
Turns out that it is not.
Because if you're
running snapshots,
the price for
snapshots or Nearline
is the same, exactly the same.
With Coldline you could
go a little bit cheaper.
But then you have the problem
that, for Nearline or Coldline,
creating a snapshot
from that data
is not as simple as creating
a snapshot from a snapshot.
Because when you
have a snapshot,
everything you need to do if
you want to create a new disk
is just one click
and you're done.
Or one REST API.
Or one gcloud command.
So it is way simpler.
And unless you have
a huge amount of data
that you were storing in--
you were backing up--
and then in that case,
as you were mentioning,
maybe you should be
using persistent disks.
So unless you're using
a huge amount of data
on persistent disks and that
little difference in price
makes a lot of difference,
I'd say that you should just
simply use snapshots.
Because once the
price is [INAUDIBLE]--
it's actually the
same as Nearline,
and they're much easier to use
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
worth noting that snapshots
are diff based,
so you don't have
to grab the whole thing again,
which you might necessarily
need to do if you're going
to shift all your stuff over
to some sort of cloud
storage instance.
What's also kind
of cool about them
is that snapshots are
globally available.
So if you want to
restore them, you
can restore them to any
zone within your project.
So that makes them
super, super useful,
especially if you want to
capture an operating system as
well as your data
at the same time.
So your recovery
time is pretty sweet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
think that in that case
it is important to take
into account that when
you have a snapshot
and you're copying it
across networks,
across regions, there's
a fee associated to that.
Because you're actually
transferring data
across networks, so there's like
ingress and egress and stuff
that you take into account.
Very related to that, if
you store that information
into cloud storage, into
Nearline or Coldline,
you also have a cost associated
to reading all that data.
So we have a bunch of
links in the show notes.
There's actually a
very good article
that we found while doing the
research for this question,
which the name is "Designing
a Disaster Recovery Plan."
It covers instant snapshots
and way more than that.
So maybe even a good
topic for an episode.
I don't know who would
be a good person to have.
But, what do we do
when things go wrong?
Not internally,
that would be SRE.
But if you're a customer, what
are the kind of things that you
can do to prepare for any
mistakes that could happen
in your production?
MARK MANDEL: I like that
idea lot, we should do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
think that with that
the question has been answered.
So thank you, FRWillia23,
for that great question.
I hope that you will be
happy with the answer.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, I know you
just got back from China
but what are you up to lately?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
A bunch of things.
I'm going to be in
New York next week.
On Monday I'll be presenting
at the Google Developer Group
in New York City with Brad.
He'll be talking
about class functions.
I'll be doing a couple
demos on Cloud Endpoints.
After that, my next
trip is something
that I did not expect,
but I will be going
to Buenos Aires in Argentina.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
What are you doing there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I will
be going to an event
that I'm not sure
is already public,
but it is a Google event
that's going to happen there.
I will make sure to get
a couple of extra days
so I can run some meet-ups.
MARK MANDEL: Very, very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: So, we will be
hosting the Extra Life and Play
Crafting Game Jam
here in San Francisco.
I'll be around for that.
So if you're in the
area and you want
to raise some money for kids
in hospitals, please come by.
A couple of weeks after that I
will be off at the Nordic Game
Conference in Malmo, Sweden.
I'm probably mispronouncing
that terribly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think you're
pronouncing it correctly.
It's Malmo.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
Malmo?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
pretty sure, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
Wow, I usually mess
that up entirely.
But yeah, I think that's the
stuff that I've been doing.
I do have a blog post
that I just put live.
I know I've mentioned
on the podcast
a couple of times
talking about running
game servers on Kubernetes.
I just put the first
part of a series up live,
so I'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice!
And since you're
mentioning that,
I'll also mention
my just for fun
video that I released four
days ago, so that's pretty new.
The previous episode was
on the context package
and how to use it.
This one is on how
to implement it.
So if you're interested in
seeing me hack stuff in Go,
check it out.
We have a link in
the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, thank you
again for spending time with me
and doing another podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.